I know you and your family are in
isolation as we all are how's everybody
doing you guys holding up okay we're
okay you know everybody gets their turn
to have a like a mini mini breakdown
right I don't know how it is it your
house but it's it's well I would say
we're fine but then there were moments
where you realize we're not supposed to
be together this much exactly yes my my
my wife's pet name for me which got
retired for long time has come back into
play in this quarantine time and she
lovingly lovingly refers to me as the
grumpy old [ __ ] and that is he she has
made a reappearance absolutely
are you the grumpy old [ __ ] sometimes
absolutely I am I have a little bit of a
short fuse and we'll irritable I was the
kid you know who and your little league
team who if I made a decent play at
third and threw it to you and you were
at first and you and you and you bobbled
it I would go you saw I was that kid so
and that has carried over a bit into my
adulthood and like for example like a
Mario Kart for example has figured big
you know my son is about to be 11 and I
uh we play a lot of the Mario Kart is
one of the things we do duh sure but I
had to put that like when when we were
pregnant with that with sad son I was
going through a little bit of uh of an
edgy time in my life I frankly I was
newly sober I'll say it there there I
said it
good for you thank you yes about I guess
twelve thirteen years ago
and a little edgy and I I think I had
crossed addicted shall we say into video
games because there I am playing Mario
Kart alone against like online against
teenagers I think mostly in Japan who
knew all the cheat codes and I didn't
and I would get so infuriated Conan
losing to these kids that have been
screaming in wage at the television set
just screaming and my wife was finally
like look I understand you going through
stuff but once the baby comes like
have this in the house I just you cannot
be thinking what was happening
specifically in the in Mario Kart it's
making you scream you said they're using
a cheat code what's happening laughs
amilia are with the Mario Kart but
there's a thing you can get which is
like the star which is you become this
like rainbow lit up and you can't you're
invulnerable you go twice as fast as the
other racers nothing can hurt you and
these kids they had a cheek or they
could just call it up at will so even if
I beat them in the race they would pull
up that rainbow thing and they run right
over me and I would I bad in particular
with driving saying that's what makes it
beautiful is that something it's
supposed to be beautiful and Landorus
great explosion of rainbows and
marshmallows that makes your Mario Kart
zoom through the air and you're
screaming well that's good if you happen
your opponents hate it I know I'm still
I'm screaming bloody murder at a rainbow
cart and while luigi in his rainbow
trail yeah and so I'm flipping out one
day like that and it comes to me and my
fantasy by the way is to smash the
television I won't just take it and
smash the screen of the TV which would
be you know that would be a lose-lose
right so but it came to me the clouds
parted I realized this from when I can't
do this anymore
and I took the the video game console
took it outside into the concrete and I
smashed it into bits itsy-bitsy bits and
it was great it was a win-win III I got
it all out and it ensured that I that I
quit playing and you know I my wife came
home and she's like hey you do I'm like
I think I have good news and I showed
her the game smashed to smithereens and
she would the terrified look on her face
when yeah that's great honey
congratulations to us as well great here
you are 13 years later you know and all
as well you know you didn't I don't
think you've screamed at your son I
think you I haven't I've got I have to
watch it die for have to be forever
vigilant I get real educate games real
game 7 yeah with the stuff my son can
in Mario Kart now I just have to accept
that you know this is cart of getting
older you know I mean part of getting
old and you have to accept it